we all wanted Trump to succeed in 2016
when he was promising things like
building the wall he didn't do it and
that and people take great issue with
this on the campaign Trail he didn't do
the things he said he was going to do he
didn't you know take the government and
reduce its footprint and get these
bureaucracy uh get the bureaucracy under
control and just be the great disruptor
that he said he was going to be in fact
a lot of stuff was status quo under
Donald
Trump
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the press secretary to Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis Brian Griffin Brian welcome
to the ruin report hey Dave thanks for
having me Brian I know we've got limited
time here and I don't think I would be
doing either of of us any favors if we
just uh took it easy on each other so
I'm going to dive in real quick and uh
let's see what we come up with so first
off Newsome to santis this is the big
debate Florida Cali what should we
expect out of this thing not just
Florida and California Dave because
because that debate is over everybody
has already voted with their feet people
left California in the hundreds of
thousands by the way I think that
includes you and came to Florida this is
about the future of our country what
kind of country do we want to live in do
we want to live in the California Gavin
Newsome model of collapsed cities of
prosecutors unwilling to go after crime
unsafe streets of high costs of
homelessness of Perpetual problems that
never seem to get solved or do we want
to live under the free state of Florida
model that was built thanks to Governor
Ronda santis where he safeguarded
Liberties um we've got uh prosperity in
Florida people have jobs I'm covid was
treated in a way that respected people's
lives and Liberty so what is the model
we want for the future of our country
that's what this debate is all about all
right so that was my softball and now I
got to give you the tough one which is
that it seems to me that that the one
thing that the santis campaign has been
unable to do is capture the zit guys
nobody thinks he's a bad dude nobody
thinks the policies are bad nobody
thinks there's any flubs or any failures
or anything like that but there seems to
be something else that it hasn't been
able to catch with I think that might
change uh with this Newsome debate but
do you think that that's a fair
criticism and is there anything that can
be done if you do think it's a fair
criticism is there anything that can be
done say in the next you know month and
a half before we hit Iowa I don't think
that matches what we see on the ground
when we're talking to people when they
come to our events when they meet with
the governor they get it this guy knows
what he's talking about he is 10 layers
deep on every item and detail he knows
policy he's going to come into the White
House day one he's going to have
Personnel ready and in place he's going
to have plans he's going to be able to
execute and anybody that takes a look at
Florida can see he says what he means he
does what he says he's going to do and
he has put win after win on the board
for conservatives and just for kind of
decent honest hardworking people uh to
be able to live their lives normally
that's what people want in this country
and when you get all of the media
chatter out of the way when you get the
polling you know class out of the way
that's what it comes down to that's what
Ronda santis
represents do you think that some of
that uh that Zeitgeist thing whether
whether you agree with the premise or
not is is partly because he's so
competent and because he's good and
because there aren't flubs so the media
doesn't know what to do with it I think
there's a lot of people that want to
attack Ronda santis that have nothing to
attack him on because I think he has a
solid record he's a good honest
hardworking Family Man and he's put on
the board more detailed policies and
plans for this country than any other
candidate so sure people are going to
look for ways to try to make an attack
but again you know Twitter's not real
life even corporate news media is not
real life what's real life are the
people's concerns on the ground that we
are hearing from Ronda santz is
addressing those and his policy
proposals he's addressing those
specifically with people that's why
we're going to win Iowa and do well on
this primary and win this primary what
what is it that you're hearing from the
people in Iowa because for months even
before the governor had announced when I
was traveling I had a lot of people cuz
everyone knew how much I love Florida
and what was going on here a lot of
people saying I appreciate Trump I'm
ready for disantis it you guys have been
tweeting out a lot of videos lately of
just PE just R you know random or decent
citizens of Iowa kind of saying the same
thing it's not that they hate Trump it's
just that they're seeing something else
different we all wanted Trump to succeed
in 2016 when he was promising things
like building the wall he didn't do it
and that and people take great issue
with this on the campaign Trail he
didn't do the things he said he was
going to do he didn't you know take the
government and reduce its footprint and
get these bureaucracy uh get the
bureaucracy under control and just be
the great disruptor that he said he was
going to be in fact a lot of stuff was
status quo under Donald Trump so we need
someone who's going to come in and
actually do these things Ronda santis
everything he promised he was going to
do in Florida he did he overd delivered
if Trump had built that wall Dave we
wouldn't be able to have the situation
that we have today you know even if Joe
Biden continued his policies that he's
got now of an open border and not you
know willfully not wanting to uh tackle
this issue a wall would be there
nonetheless and as many people would not
be able to come into this country so if
Trump had delivered we'd be in a
different position we're not there Ronda
Sanchez will deliver where Trump failed
to do so all right so now let me ask you
one of the tough ones which is the same
question that I asked the governor last
time I hit him which is what do you do
about the ride or die Trump folks the
people that they don't it's not that
they don't care about the things that
you just laid out but they're just going
I'm Trump all the way is there any way
to kind of shave off some of those
people uh to the movement that you guys
are trying to build of of course we're
speaking with people directly on the
ground which makes a difference and Dave
we've had plenty of people in Iowa and
other early states that said I came to
your event and I was going to vote for
Trump but now I'm going to vote for you
uh because Governor Dan santis lays out
those spefic specifics and this message
does resonate with people again we
supported what Donald Trump wanted to do
in 2016 he just didn't deliver he got
distracted with things uh he put bad
people around him we've got a lot of
chaos right now but Ronda santis is the
antidote to that chaos and as you make
that case to people on the ground and in
person you turn things around and that's
what we're
doing what do you make of how Trump has
treated Governor Dan
santis again I think it's probably the
of looking for something to attack him
on because he's got such a stellar
record Ronda santis is just a a a died
in the wool conservative I mean he
understands details uh he can quote the
founding fathers off the cuff like
nobody I've ever seen in office and he's
a good person so if you're looking for
something to take issue with you really
have to search deep for that and Ronda
santis so that's why we feel good about
this I mean look Dave we're going into
Iowa okay we have um only a you know
several weeks until the caucus we've got
got more people committed to caucus
we've got more than 30,000 committed to
caucus more than the last couple of Iowa
winners have gone into uh the race with
and and one we've got Governor Kim
Reynolds on our side um Bob Vander plats
just endorsed us we've got big voices
like Steve da so the groundwork is in
place every Iowa County has a campaign
chair uh and in fact we're about to hit
our 99th County visited Ronda santis
will have performed the full grassly
ahead of the Iowa caucus that's the type
of work ethic that wins that state and
then Iowa propels you know momentum into
future victories so we feel very good
about the state of this campaign yeah
and you know now I can give you one of
the easy ones I mean you know I'm I'm
seeing that myself and that's what I'm
hearing from a lot of people and
everything else one of the bizarre ones
to me is that Kim Reynolds who's an
incredibly popular governor in Iowa she
endorsed D santis and it basically
wasn't covered by the mainstream media
you would think that if Kim Reynolds
who's popular endorses a guy supposedly
50 points down she might be committing
political suicide at least write that
article but instead they just didn't
cover it at all well no look I think
that Kim reyolds you know as she said
she did looked at all of the candidates
and made a determination that Ronda
santis one had the best vision for the
future of this country and two had the
best chance of winning uh the general
election and the primary and all of that
goes into an endorsement and Dave she's
not the only endorsement that we have
there like I said we've got Bob Vander
plat and we've got Steve daon we've got
41 state legislators all of whom believe
that Ronda santis is the best choice in
this race and that means something I
think that means something to Ians
certainly means something to us so yeah
look media narratives are going to be
what they are and I think everybody has
different you know dogs in this race but
at the end of the day the people who
come out to our events okay the voter
right they care about the things that
are affecting them not the media
narratives but the things that they see
and they feel in their lives every day
the prices of gas the safety of their
streets the prices of food right how we
stand on the world World stage these
things where people are going to base
their decision on when it comes to
making a selection in this race and
Ronda santis on every single one of
those issues is the best candidate yeah
you know it's funny having lived in
Florida it'll be two years in about two
weeks from now uh all the the quote
unquote problems that we have in Florida
are are the functions of success I mean
we have some traffic in South Florida
because there's a lot of people moving
here our house prices kind of high a lot
of people moving here but we're building
fast both homes and infrastructure which
I've discussed with the governor before
um do you think that that the whole
country wants as much Freedom as Florida
is uh trying to export do you think it's
possible that places like Cali and New
York that they are so far gone that they
they wouldn't even know it if it smacked
them in the face I think that Common
Sense always resonates with people I
think that the American you know
founding principles and Ethos still
resonates with people and I think people
want that and we know that Dave again
because everybody has left these blue
jerse jurisdictions and they've come to
red jurisdictions and more than any
other jurisdiction they've come to
Florida because of what Ronda santis not
only promised but delivered
on what would you like to see happen at
the next debate you know obviously
there's a sort of uh let's say orange
elephant not in the room and that
creates this odd atmosphere there
because they should all kind of be going
after him if he's supposedly number one
nobody really goes after the governor I
think for some of the reasons you said
and then there's some like l little mini
bickering between them but it doesn't
seem to move the dial much is there
something you'd like to see when we get
to this uh fourth and final debate well
look we're going to participate in the
debates I think they're important we'd
love for Trump to show up and debate
right because I think he owes it to the
American people uh this nomination is
not something that is handed to people
or that anybody is entitled to you know
made the best candidate win we'll do the
debates we'll have those conversations I
hope we have a robust conversation
that's issue focused but then we want to
get back on the ground and continue the
hard work of campaigning of reaching
people one-on-one of listening to their
concerns and of uh demonstrating the
policies and the ideas that Ronda Sanz
has to address those concerns that's how
these campaigns are won that's what's
going to matter at the end of the day
tell me something about the governor
that people do not see I think everyone
sees the competency they see the decency
they see a good family man they see a
beautiful wife they see three good kids
everyone gets it nobody's debating it
you're spending a lot of time with him
now on the road give me give me
something that people don't see he's a
good guy behind the scenes it's the same
you get in front of the cameras right
and a lot of politicians and a lot of
leaders are not like that but he is the
real deal he's very genuine um and I'm
just honored to be working for him
because I have been able to see him in
those moments when the cameras aren't on
um and he you know he he acts justly and
and says what he means and and speaks
with truth and I think that's important
um we've lost that in American
leadership uh certainly in the
Democratic party we've got too many
people in the Republican party uh that
are um deceptive I think with the
American people we've got congress with
all of their own agendas we've got
people that are bogged down with all
types of you know personal problems in
their lives that keep them distracted
from being able to deliver for the
American people Ronda sanus doesn't have
those issues um he is going to be able
to put wins on the board because that is
what he is going to be Mission focused
on from day one and he will score uh win
after win and not just that Dave he
doesn't just you know do the things he
says he's going to do he takes ground
from the left he's been reclaiming our
institutions here in Florida in a way
that we diely desperately need um in in
America let me ask you one other thing
Brian because one thing that I hear from
OG Floridians to the new Floridians is
oh man I love the santis but if we if he
becomes the nominee and he becomes the
president then what happens to the free
state of Florida and I think that is a
very legitimate concern or another
version of it it is you know that the
federal government is so screwed up that
maybe even he the best guy that we have
can't fix it so why bother sending him
out there let's just keep fortifi
fortifying Florida what would you say to
the people who are here in Florida right
now and want to make sure no matter what
that Florida continues uh all that
goodness that brought people like me
here I mean let me take both of these so
this is America right we can always we
can do big things and accomplish what we
need to accomplish um nothing is too far
gone in this country to be able to fix
it we just have to put our best foot
forward we need the best candidate as
our nominee to face the Democrats
whoever they put up in 20124 to win and
then to fight for us on issue after
issue until we win on issue after issue
to reclaim our institutions from the
left and to get this country back on
track with a nod to Common Sense and the
concerns of the American people that's
why we need to nominate Ronda santis
Florida you know Ronda santis has been
able to not just deliver policy wins
through executive uh leadership but
through the legislature also so Florida
is set up for generations to benefit
from the policies that Rona santis the
legislative accomplishments that Ronda
DeSantis was able to accomplish while
he's been governor also he put together
a very big Coalition in fact a historic
coalition to win in Florida in the last
election we've now got more than 500,000
Republicans uh more of those than
Democrats so that's going to last you
know for a long time in this state he's
been able to bring lasting effective
change to Florida he'll do the same for
the country that's why we should
nominate him the only Democrat I've met
in my entire time in Miami is my dentist
and I think he's on the fence right now
i' I've been working on him although
it's a it's a little tough when he's got
all that stuff in your mouth and you're
trying to
explain what Freedom's all about Brian
it's media would like yeah exactly uh
Brian it's going to be an interesting uh
what month and a half until we hit that
caucus but uh you know who I'm rooting
for so I wish you lot of luck thank you
so much appreciate that thanks for
having me on if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of nonstop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell